que voyez-vous sur cette image il y a
deux possibilités soit vous voyez un
canard soit vous voyez un lapin
peut-être que vous voyez les deux mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu en premier le
lapin canard c'est une image qui
illustre la différence de perception et
l'impossibilité pour une perception
d'être en même temps une chose et une
autre vous pouvez voir le canard puis le
lapin ou le lapin puis le canard
successivement mais pas simultanément le
lapin canard ce ne sont pas deux images
c'est une seule et même image c'est un
seul et même fait mais sur lequel
peuvent se plaquer de perception
radicalement différentes
tout est une question de perception